fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby big Jay's already got us
laughing so hard quit two two stories we
can't really repeat although there is a
special on YouTube where there's an
audible for 10 40. at 10 40. I don't
want to hold fart on this poor woman's
special
who took a pass that was okay let's edit
that oh that's so good she didn't hear
it so God bless her um and then uh and
then yeah and then uh but tell the story
about what you were about to tell
because it's just too oh about uh about
one-up liars yeah one in your life
people who uh whatever you tell you know
well man I just had my first threesome
that's cool because I actually hooked up
a Four Chicks once at the same time like
that guy my favorite guy yeah and uh and
we found this out about a guy who worked
for Lewis on his uh Louis J Gomez on a
street scene when he was selling tickets
and doing shows and one thing we decided
it was meeb's Nate bar gatsy was there a
couple of other Lewis's guys Dave Smith
and me and we we went to a bar after
their show and we're like let's all just
tell crazy stories they're outlandish
for us already yeah and let's see if he
goes up there I don't remember
everyone's except the few were uh I told
that I mean I even made it so like
cartoonish I'm like yeah I was down at
the Docks one day and uh 25 guys tried
to fight me he goes and I was like I
didn't like win but I was able to get
out like I was able to fight my way
through he goes dude he goes I had a
fight he goes the South Street he board
talks because I had a fight down there
it was like 30 guys or something it was
something nuts he's like same thing
though he's like I didn't like kick ass
but like I did get away oh it was some
[__] and then it was like you know
someone [__] so many girls he [__]
a few more you know he had like a seven
some for someone else's fivesome and
whatever and Nate bargatsi just goes uh
it was quiet almost the whole time
almost like a like a mystery guy in the
shadows he goes I killed a guy once and
this guy goes with his drink he goes
dude he goes I gotta take a piss he goes
don't tell a story goes he goes I killed
a guy too
don't tell a story yet are you ready to
take a piss but I killed a guy too hold
that thought yeah I've also responsible
Nick's worse than would do that [__]
makes Horseman always dead like my dad
was a fighter pilot and he's like my dad
was an astronaut
great oh man I love that [__] people
like that it seems like that is no
longer on the team no no and the uh I
think he's a family now but it's so long
ago at this point but it's uh by the way
his his uh murder story Nate's was great
because they had to conjure one up when
he said that he said he was uh shooting
uh bow and arrows in the woods and it
accidentally hit a guy goes and I just
left he's like so I just think I just
left from there to die or something I
think he even said it was in his leg
none of it made sense yeah and this guy
came back and said he got into a bar
fight outside with a guy in the fight I
think they say the guy took his shirt
off and he was covered in like
Yakuza tattoos and he beat him up till
he was unconscious and then he left and
he goes and the neck this is my favorite
part of it because he goes uh
he goes the next day in the uh Village
Voice they said Yakuza member found dead
in the thing I'm like the bi-weekly Arts
newspaper The Village Voice
he said the village boys
and you could uh see what's going on at
local comedy clubs and maybe Japanese
underground or also reports on murders
in the Japanese underground
our friend Mitch went to his high school
reunion it was after like you know
10-year reunion Mr director yeah yeah
and and he goes and he's like uh where's
where's uh Fitzy because Fitzy was
always crazy Fitzy was the guy who would
get on the hood of your car at 60 miles
an hour and everybody's like ah
what do you mean uh where is he goes
he's in jail man I was like what do you
do I'm selling drugs or everything goes
no man and it's like you tell him now
you tell him it's like what did the
[__] tell me and he goes well
he would go to Applebee's and then the
manager was this guy he was a nice guy
and he lured the manager after getting
to know him out to a cornfield raped him
and then tried to kill him but the
manager Got Away Classics
[__] Fitzy [__] a guy in the
cornfield he's got a rape a dude to
cornfield nuts I mean I mean have him
over just know what you're inviting over
there's crazy and then there's got to
rape a guy in a cornfield crazy and then
try to kill him and then botch that yeah
and then get the kill so he got caught
yeah so he's still in jail so Fitzy's
probably not not a good guy to mix him
with Society because that gets that's
what that was a real story it's a real
story
that's true we did lose the Yakuza
member yeah well Sammy the book ravana
tells that story about how his when he
was working with Paul Castellano Paul
Castellano bring up Paul Castellano and
the guy from Purdue the chicken Purdue
guy and his and castellano's daughter
had a boyfriend and I guess the
boyfriend was kind of associated he was
trying to be a tough guy he'll be real
badass today yeah Paul yeah seniors yeah
so uh just Chicken King says he dealt
with me
I'll [__] call him yeah let me see
some pictures can I get some peepers on
his daughter though yeah we will in a
second how gone is the mafia okay so
there's no Sammy the bull gravity was on
the podcast now there's Purdue
up there you see that that's Castellano
so his boyfriend I mean her boyfriend
goes you look like Purdue
so
Castellano goes to Sammy he goes uh hey
uh kill that kill kill my kill him I
want him dead because it looks similar
because he because he looks he felt
insulted by that comparison he goes to
kill her kill him
so he he had his boyfriend he had his
daughter's boyfriend meet the guys for
some business deal and and Sammy the
bull goes so uh the guy goes there they
shoot him
and then uh Roy De Mayo's crew comes in
with suitcases and briefcases they saw
him up into tiny pieces just because he
look like it takes a half hour less they
bleed him saw him up yeah and they put
him in and he just they just walked out
without and that was the end just
because he looked similar because he's
because the boyfriend said to Paul
Castellano you look like Purdue and he
was like Christ oh that's a capital
offense I'm gonna have to have you
killed and chopped up and disappear he's
definitely an uglier I know you're
that's your boyfriend but he's got to go
yeah sorry she was like where'd my
boyfriend go he just looks I don't know
honey oh come here
good guy yeah now all those mob does
because the mob they're not shaking
anybody down I got an iPhone big I
talked to I talk to I FaceTime with
Sammy the bull yeah he's obsessed with
him well no I I I I he said we FaceTime
it's hilarious and I go I'm in traffic
and [__] at on the JFK and and I go
uh I go hey what what this traffic never
ends you this construction [__] you were
you ran all of New York's construction
what the [__] is going on and he goes ah
yes he and he broke it all down for me
the Uber driver was like holy [__] he
broke down exactly how it all works he
goes nah we don't give a [__] if you sit
in traffic we got to make money so we
have the guys work for two hours a day
because that's when traffic is not as
big I don't gives a [__] about you and
and he I said could you get away with
any of the [__] you do back then he goes
no everybody's got cameras no this
camera's literally everywhere you can't
do it yeah
Steve Jobs killed the mafia yeah you
can't you can't get away with a goddamn
thing on win for it to come to Mexico
though because those cartels are a
little out of control different animal
though
though I mean I still we've yet to have
the realism of like the SVU computer
of like zoom in fix it yeah clear it up
turn that up for me a little bit yeah
just a perfect picture of that yeah just
a second there he is and we are
in
got some [__] me and soda would do
that on the bonfire at the time he goes
she's gonna move some things around here
see if we can put this over here type in
the screen thing and we are
in
it never amounts to anything at all no
the Philadelphia mob when I was younger
you grew up in Philly yeah my wife is
from was it oh yeah they were like
clownish by the time like I knew what
they were just no respect it was like
now they were just like young people
also there was like the sons of all the
people and they was like go to Atlantic
City and [__] [__] up and yeah but then
get kicked out and have to you know I
mean yeah
we are they're like we do know who you
are and beat it
now now they're doing like uh I don't
know if all of them do but it's like
drug trafficking like human trafficking
right like there's no shaking that's in
countries that get away with it like
Russia [__] sex trafficking is Big
here oh yeah but it comes from places
like Mexico did you ever I remember
in the handful of times I went to the
massage places when I was younger just a
handful handful yeah and uh the well it
got sad quick I also worked I was going
to say the thing with the mafia also
that's like probably still going to some
degree was I worked for a guy if he was
in the mafia he liked to dress and act
like he was although that said he had a
koi pond in like a townhouse like
attached to other houses but his front
had a koi pond his little three by three
yeah uh but he ran the company I worked
for that was uh at daytime you go
dressed as whatever for kids parties and
at night time it was uh
bouncing for strippers and escorts at CD
Bachelor parties or weird guys houses
yeah that's yeah so the mafia is still
around the end of that world yes yeah
for sure they never got your size just
sitting there waiting
yeah you'd be you'd be a good bouncer
cauliflower heirs just a big kid not too
nice someone's like come on man no you
don't have to I'll give you the money
next week I'm like all right no you just
have to be quiet and just kind of look
at them like that yeah he goes if you
talk to him he goes he goes ah seven
days right what's yeah like beat up in
seven yeah
yeah that was funny when I did that job
too I didn't understand why
it's like a different generation like
when it got like kind of like hairy and
some some of those driving strippers or
escorts
um I'd go back to the guy like how am I
by far and wide
the youngest largest person doing this
and it seems like everybody else seems
to be like an old man and I'm like how
are they getting out of these situations
and they were like they have guns and I
was like oh he's like you don't have a
gun I was like no he's like you want a
gun I was like no because I'm I'll pull
it out way early yeah of course the
first sign of anything I go everyone
just stay calm the girls want to [__]
tonight everyone stay calm I like I like
what Christopher Walken did in King of
New York he just just a gun here and
they try to Rob him and he goes whoa and
he opens his jacket and he goes how
about that and they were like oh [__]
just kind of efflicted he just went how
about that from Francis grabbed it and
shot him in the dick well he threw him
he threw them a bunch of money he goes
come to The Plaza Hotel tell them Frank
White sent you they were like damn did
you ever play the great game if one
decision was different in a movie it
just goes
like fine we used to always say the like
First Blood yeah first Rambo yeah he's
driving the car he just didn't have such
a weird attitude in the car and he was
like yeah I just got back from Nam it
was my friend I went to go visit his dad
and he's with Brian Danny he goes you
like roast beef
how about I take you for the best roast
beef it's cooked like three hours later
the cops come in he goes you got to meet
Johnny Rambo this guy's nuts
if he just wasn't weird in the car at
all don't be weird in the car he was
just quiet and like
and the guy was like yeah I think
rightfully so I want this guy out of my
town he's been weird there'd be no
movies
I never thought of that that's such a
funny bit a quick decision in the
beginning hey answer me how about
answering me I don't answer the question
straight forward like John Wick there's
no John Wick they don't [__] with his
dog I hear the fourth one is really good
just doesn't take the fight with Rocky
just goes nah I'm gonna get a couple
more tune-up fights before I jump in
with the champ because why you just
killed my friend that's the only way to
solve this yeah I got a good prior
commitment
contract it's a bunch of leaders
there he goes yeah it doesn't really
doesn't it's the fight the matchmakers
wouldn't do this one for me I just
watched Rocky again with my son the
first holds up oh yeah holds up fight
scenes tricky because nobody's making
contact and and uh that's every movie
though even today's movie but the
training montage is much shorter than I
remembered it and there's no sparring
really it's just push-ups
Rocky 2 is where they learned the
training montage when she has the baby
and so they still play that the Sixers
or Eagles could be down by
insurmountable points with 24 seconds
left and when she goes I want you to do
one thing
what are we waiting for dinner
all right we're coming out of the break
two minutes left Sixers down by 37. oh
right
for a remote like everyone would just go
on for the training montage [__] dude
are you a big uh Phillies fan like all
the teams are you like a sports guy or
no I'm a big Sports guy on the two teams
I give a [__] about which is the Eagles
and Sixers the only things like I never
grew up playing hockey yeah I went yeah
you took me oh [__] yeah he took me uh
Shane and Mark Normand Bill burden uh no
Bert question it was like kind of a last
minute offer you made to me and I was
like yeah I'll go I was like that's
crazy and I'll tell you what
leaving a gazillion dollar ticket event
when the team loses feels as shitty as
when you just yeah hell yeah paid for
yourself you wouldn't change else were
sad pants oh yeah absolutely Shameless
Eagles too yeah yeah it was cool we were
doing those uh
like sports emotion things too and I'm
like all week before we saw each other I
go it was so cool we get to share this
to get share this together
[Laughter]
my heart is flooded with joy for what we
were about to um
share this together I wouldn't want to
share this with anything but you I mean
so I had been watching hype videos from
like 2016 on YouTube showing Bert's crew
who has the Orange is like no you got to
see Brian Dawkins he's the guy like he
ended the guy's like
I had a guy said that to me he goes why
don't we get one uh it says saying when
are we getting together he goes when do
I get to see your smiling face again
ah man I don't know now I'm so busy
remember that comic of The Comedy Store
Facebook we're in the middle
conversation
and he goes I can see Brad we're in the
middle it's like me Rogan Brian Chris
we're all sitting there hey how you
doing yeah it's good to see you yeah
well I love what you did up there hey
you know what the same area you wanna
you wanna play cat catch someday it's
gonna get out there in the park and just
throw the ball around and Brennan went
what do you mean you didn't even get it
[__] I don't know just get the ball
and just throw it around back and forth
I love doing that if you ever want to do
that I mean we're in the same thing he's
certain it's code for something yeah
yeah Brandon just looked at me goes
definitely
foreign
come get some then I got helium April 20
22. Where Are You Gonna bait before we
get into others uh I'm at the ice house
Saturday one show only 8 P.M shopping
friends at the new Ice House Atlanta
Georgia April 13th through the 15th La
Jolla comedy store that's uh
wow now I'm jumping across the pond
Belfast Glasgow
law school London London Dublin Dublin
Dublin June 25th give you some
thinkboy.com
better help you got to take care of your
brain not just your body dude sometimes
talking to somebody your friends if I
got problems it's not the same as
talking to a licensed therapist it's not
the same as talking about professional
and that's where better help comes in
they connect you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery wherever you
are from the comfort of your home well
you don't have to be in a waiting room
you have to go like talk you can do it
literally really they can match you up
on under 48 hours with a licensed
professional like online it's an
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule all you do is fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist you can switch
therapists anytime you want no
additional charge all right discover
your potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com fighter today and get
temps off your first month better help
you wake up and check your credit score
who does that dude okay well chime does
okay look if your financial goals feel
Out Of Reach they don't have to be okay
Chimes got a secured credit Builder Visa
credit card wow you can start building
credit with your own money through
on-time payments and small everyday
purchases like groceries streaming gas
memory see an increase of 30 points to
their credit score on average charm
reports your payments to the major
credit bureaus to help you build credit
over time all with no annual fees no
large security deposits or credit checks
to apply uh so here it is start making
your financial dreams a reality with
chime
c-h-i-m-e signing up only takes about
two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score so get started at chime.com
fighter that is chime dots.com fighter
do me a favor and read that mandatory
disclosure if you can't just write it no
just go ahead and read that mandatory
exposure do you have about it's not a
big deal oh you're going into seizures
okay the child
Visa credit card is issued by stride
Bank do you know about stride Bank n a
and how about this pursuant uh to a
license with Visa USA tribe checking
account and a 200 qualifying direct
deposit required to apply for the
secured chime credit Builder Visa credit
card based on a study conducted by
Experian I bet you have you ever heard
of Experian of course not uh credit
Builder members observed an average of
30 points f i c o score eight increase
after eight months with regular on-time
payments results May Vary brain has gone
blind results May Vary see chime.com for
details out of network ATM only about a
half or more hour half hour
um out of network ATM withdrawal fees
May apply except at MoneyPass ATMs in a
7-Eleven did you know that 7-Eleven yep
or any all point or VISA plus Alliance
ATM so that's something do you write
that down chime.com fighter there you go
you've been all over you talked about
yourself non-stop promo man yeah I am
yeah yeah they got me running nuts
it's called dog belly live from skank
Fest we did it uh skank Fest Vegas last
year dog belly um yes from one of the
jokes in it it was named by Dan Soder
actually when he watched it he was like
you should call it that smart dude I'm
just gonna call it live from skank Fest
now is your uh is the fan base of skank
Fester they uh I mean are they are the
are they a very forgiving crowd
us gang Fest they are I'm talking about
your the uh
what do you mean the the Legion of
skanks yeah yeah fan base are so Savage
they're Savage [__] yeah but
they're his that's his no but they're
also like here's the thing here's the
great greatest thing about them
and the problem with it we've made this
like
safe zone for like just [__] go for
it yeah and the thing is 90 of them are
just much money do you know what I mean
that's why they're fans so it's like
they're going like even like their
shittiest thing like for the most part
they think they're going for it and I
tried to and and that's a good thing too
because they're like I get they're
engaged and that's great and they're the
best comedy fans and that's what I
remember um
my favorite thing with our audience was
when the guys we [__] girls did skank
Fest the first time when they showed up
they were like well here we go we're
gonna walk into this like because
they've had like [__] with us on air
before you know we've gone back and
forth they're all great once you get in
there once you engage they're great it's
Once you walk in there not only if they
look at it as like even if it's been
like a tumultuous thing with them
it's like meeting Erica Kane
and hating Susan Lucci do you know what
I mean like it's not that thing it's
like it's like no you love Susan Lucci
because she's everyone like well that's
why we know we're all ourselves yeah but
trust like in their minds like they're
so removed from it we're characters in a
thing yeah you know what I mean and so
that's how and when they see the
characters whether it's someone who they
[__] on or they uh overly dude I mean
they're so excited to see all of
everyone because no one's ever like
that's why are you guys hanging out with
the guys we [__] girl like it's like
yeah they're our friends Louis was like
have Brennan come on the [__] on the
show it'll be a blast yeah yeah I think
they're hoping to have you guys a skank
Fest because all you guys are good guys
like we were together dance from my
[__] same home I know it's so crazy
what a wacky town of insane things that
happened there I mean that throw a dart
at a town that's had so much [__] drama
Colorado the Aurora Colorado all the
school shootings a lot of mass cool
shootings essentially the shooting at
the The Joker yeah yeah then a whole
documentary on Netflix about a guy who
built a motel in Aurora
his wife would just bring him food up in
the attic so he just watch girls and
people [__] yeah oh yeah oh he had
cameras in the in the hotel room he
didn't have camera just holes he would
just do it he didn't want to record it
he wanted to watch it and he would just
he would just lay in an attic with all
the vents over them and he would just go
up there and his wife would just like
she was just a sad [__] that she would
just bring him out she goes here's your
turkey
there's a girl jacking off
he was his name is Gerald Foose and he's
unapologetically hilarious about all
this by the way he's not even now I
think he served jail time what yeah yeah
he's like saw a lot of [__] it was cool
one time he said there was a couple
getting ready to [__] or a girl getting
ready to masturbate it's one of those
two and he was in there and they hit the
lights like hard off like turned him off
before whatever's gonna was gonna happen
and he got Furious because he said she
was one of the hottest ones ever there
so he went and took his car and drove
his car up to the it's like a motel you
know he drove it up to the window with
his headlights on and then went back up
he lit up the room so he can go back up
there he's like ah better
would they turn off oh [__] his tie
would come through the things sometimes
if he would look up and they have to
like slurp it back up the thing
Ingenuity that's what all Aurora
Aurora is wild also uh head coach you
know Dan's best friends the head coach
of the Dolphins Aurora Colorado it's
amazing all this wacky [__] yeah man
some weird people yeah he was a smoky
hill cat McDaniel yeah yeah that's
[__] right man it's like soder's guy
it's like it's so funny to have it
that's a position
in life where it's funny having Dan know
that coach because like the stories we
have as children make sense as comedians
now you know I mean like when you tell
those weird stories like it's gonna have
this like official head of the NBA and
Dan's like you know and that was the
summer we all compared dicks and you're
like the guy was a good coach and I got
a TV yeah the guy's gonna yell at uh
Tyreek Hill yeah
it's just like us yeah this is [__]
weird when your buddy goes big time like
that yeah and you just know everything
about him yeah also like the background
like noise of like having to be like hey
how about your your boy putting that
quarterback in and his fingers going
eight different directions
hey you know maybe talk to him did you
text him about it yeah that's why like a
lot of like dictators like [__]
Saddam Hussein killed everybody from his
childhood and and who knew him when he
was coming up it's like yeah I can't
have that give me a story yeah
there's no stuff about me I I can't have
that so I'm gonna have to kill everybody
Saddam the kid who pissed himself
geography that guy's got to go
you know they in fact the the his son
was they assassinated tried to
assassinate his son son ended up not
being able to walk and then was on
crutches and stuff but tried to
assassinate him the guy who saved his
son who pulled him out of the car and
someone's in bad shape and stuff and got
help that guy I think they cut his
tongue out yes they put him in jail cut
his tongue out so he could never recount
the story about how his son was killed
so Saddam was a
did you ever
with like the the dictator type guys did
you ever see the Rodman documentary
no it goes North Korea's North Korea
it's
the maybe the wild the wonderful Whites
is a close second yeah because a lady
doing a line of meth and then walking
past her newborn baby in the hospital
and she goes future Miss America right
there
I never saw that
the Wild and wonderful Whites of West
Virginia
from us about this family who are from
Pennsylvania County Boone County uh yeah
it's it's it's that hillbilly elegy yeah
well they did well there was a
documentary years ago called the dancing
Outlaw about their like the patriarch of
this family and is this in West Virginia
it's in West Virginia it's total
violence it's there a crazy a lot of
inbred right worse yes and also like but
they also know how to work this it's
like a generations of working the system
so they're all on she's 30 by the way
that's good you're not wrong by the way
she's she's the hot they call her the
hot one
I have the family I swear to God that
that I believe 100 one of the I've been
out there I was a kid at one point
shakes a bottle of oxy goes Boone County
mate and call that kid's got a podcast
he follows me I feel like I might have
been followed by a celebrity I'm like oh
yeah
shakes the pill bottle I I had so I've
spent time there Jim I spent a lot of
time there not in the Hills not worth
100 of you know the comedy clubs no no
no no no so when I in college my buddy
had a martial arts school there
Taekwondo school one of my closest
friends
karate
yes
once every two months maybe once every
month we go up there and it was the
first time I ever I was in college it
was the first time I had ever met real
racists who had never met black people
sure and these guys were talking they
were like what you do is if they if they
come at you you act crazy because they
think it's gonna rub off on them but I
think he's gonna rub off on them black
people yeah and it was a first first
time I heard I never forgot this it was
the first time I I saw like what that
was that violence everybody has guns
everybody fights oh yeah you were not
allowed you could not go to a bar in
those areas if they didn't know you you
could not go you would get stomped there
are gypsies there are gypsies over here
no you could not if they didn't know you
had a bar there it was dangerous and how
about this I was in college and I had a
book on communism I was reading it was
for my history class I bet they beat you
up the guy said to me we were at this
Taekwondo this [__] tournament the
guy said hey bro you gotta hide that man
around here the book what do you mean he
goes you gotta hide that you can't have
that I said what do you mean he goes you
cause you'll cause a problem I said I
was with guys who would fight I was like
what are you talking about he goes
around here that would be considered
they think you might be into communism
or something there's no way they know
what it means but there's no way they
were reading that word
you gotta come he goes you in the
computers yeah well really allergy is a
book about this probably the first time
you saw karate in just jeans too this
lady they're not wearing a ghee this
lady so she rips a line of Meth
goes to the bathroom future Miss America
right there she goes home because the
baby of course needs a little extra
attention when they come to pick the
baby up as with everything that happens
legal to them in this documentary they
are blown away the child protective
services gotten involved she can't
believe it they took the baby away
they come back in the car she's
hysterically crying they took the baby
away the one that was bouncing on the
trampoline takes them immediately to
Taco Bell
where she threw the drive-through she
orders things that aren't on the menu
and gets pissy about it she has her
mozzarella sticks
then she drives the spray gun then she
drives while they're waiting for the
thing they see a family they know inside
who know peripherally I'll say is the
work because they seem to make pretty
normal people yeah and she starts way on
the horn to get their attention they
turn around they're like oh hey the
window of a building like a glass wall
not a window even of like a Taco Bell
she's screaming she goes they took her
baby her she's crying
and they're just and they're through a
window going like okay okay like they
have no idea it's it's I gotta see this
of West Virginia front to back a close
second maybe only is uh or a close uh
it's a close second but not everyone's
like that in West Virginia right it's
just like a certain part
here's the thing it's like
there's it's a part for sure but I don't
think the rest have to achieve much to
not be that you know what I mean there
you go so if you pull the best the best
out of West Virginia yeah and you throw
them and I don't know it's mine a
Chicago yeah it's not gonna go straight
yeah no one's gonna be like wow whatever
fine pal this person has
he's going over there to keep meeting
with to bring the basketball team over
there and on the second when he comes
home and he gets all this [__] from it
yeah he was sober for a while on the
trip back he just starts drinking I
remember when he went crazy and gets oh
well there's yeah he gives he cuts the
promo let me think of something brother
yeah these guys are opening a door to
North Korea yeah barrage Carl Smith
retired basketball players x-ray hip and
uh whatever is going to go solve it to a
monarchy but that Ken uh Jung right he
loved Robin it's his favorite player
because the Bulls in the 90s he's like
obsessed with it yeah so allowed Rodman
to go there because they're obsessed
with him oh yeah so he just loves him
particularly yes and he let him go he
brings those guys over to play but how
drunk he he just gets obliterate
he bows at everybody he sees and it's
not a battling culture he just does it
anyway and he treats them like toys look
at this [__] looks [__]
I make him sing
hey you don't know what the [__] he's
saying but bring up that picture there
with him and uh
Peach he's giving a speech to Kim
Jong-un and then goes
he goes and it's his birthday so I want
to say
in a Arena that's been built just for
this game with a throne for Kim Jong-un
he goes happy birthday to you audience
has no idea of this song so he's singing
it with his normal like hat the two the
the The Melody of happy birthday to you
they start going
yeah like they're clapping nowhere in
tune with this it's insane that's that
they do it rhythmically they just keep
going they just [__] mind and then
you I don't know if he's still doing
he's doing podcasts and and I was at the
mall in Westfield and he uh he came up
to me he's like glad to have you on the
podcast man I was like oh cool what do
you what do you guys talking about he's
like chicks it's relationship like no
absolutely not dude it's so funny really
yeah yeah he tells a story on Howard
Stern one time like broke his dick
[__] and he's like did you go to the
hospital he's like I have a tape on like
tape
he cut himself and he's like a carpenter
or something I taped it up so now he's
got that bend in his dick disease
apparently he was normal until he had
got estranged from his son or something
I think his son died oh really I think
it's I think his son passed away and he
started like dying his hair no he was a
weirdo a little because he was a janitor
he was a jammed some weird [__] I bet
his family his family's probably nuts
yeah I don't think just the sun did it
no I don't know I mean hilarious his
father his father's name is I didn't
know that philander the philander I mean
that's hilarious
I don't think his son died
oh I hope he didn't die I named my son
side [__] oakerson
so don't get upset [__]
[Laughter]
he only has one son six six oh it's not
three children
did one die right it says nothing about
the death no so maybe it was a strange
then yeah I think maybe I gave him too
much credit for being a weirdo yeah
maybe Brian should I mean he's in a sad
situation strange guy he's a janitor
like bro he was a Janet yeah but he was
a Transformer did you ever see the uh
the DMX leave that documentary about him
a couple years ago after he died and
they go back to like his heavy drug
years and it's him it's a it's a video I
guess on MTV of like him meeting with
his son and his son's like I just want
to have a relationship with you and have
you be my father and me be your son and
us get to know each other and start and
he was and DMS goes I can do that yeah I
can do that he goes but I need you to do
it clean and he goes
it just literally kicked somebody he's
like nope
it's cold complete with his face he goes
no no no no no no drugs rules yeah it's
like that's crazy
dude the stress it is hanging out with
you I abandon you for you that's like my
friend my friend my friend literally
famous director is going like this he
goes how do you get so much energy man I
go what do you mean he goes he says to
eat if I can have energy all the time I
want energy like that you don't have
energy because no what do you do I go
well you you know you got to stop
smoking he goes [__] no way yeah oh
that's the whole secret just tell me
what else you do I go
I don't know I can't start the
conversation like this eat more kale
what the [__] do you want hey going back
to Robin go to North Korea is it weird
that for North Dakota North Korea we
have we said Rodman or no we don't send
but they develop those relationships and
then Russia with Putin it's Steven
Seagal it's just the weirdest it's just
the weirdest odd job that was the most
famous people the 90s yeah
he goes send over Debbie Gibson
Electric youth was my [__]
and it's strange
yeah it really is like because I guess
they're they're just behind the time and
they still believe those movies are real
yeah
Steven Seagal shows up and they're like
different than the movie that was years
ago yeah was about last year's hard to
kill he's got a painted hairline he's
kind of very heavy he's different than
under siege have you ever met Steve do
all that stuff with those Russians like
he he's there with he's so heavy and
he's teaching them because they have my
best teams to go yeah you love this dude
I was at a UFC this is a long time
around UFC I'm there for do like an
appearance something so they've said all
the fighters UFC Toronto so it's GSB I
think Jake Shields and so we're sitting
in the front row we'll set I'm sorry the
second room where everyone's pretty
famous UFC fighters and I was like how
are we on the front what the [__] and
then Steven Seagal sits in in the very
front row in front of us but he's huge
so he can't see anything but before he
sat there was Josh Koscheck they kicked
Josh out and set seems to go down and he
kept standing and we can't see thing and
everyone's like John somebody should say
something I'm like yeah this [__]
seems going we can beat him up and
everyone's like you think I'm like I I
would hope [__] so so like say
something like all right watch this I'm
like shut the [__] down it turns around
[Music]
I hope I'm not adding him on this but
John Legos I'm gonna tell a story where
he goes they're doing a movie together
you know John's a real actor or an
amazing guy yeah but John's not a big
guy John's about five seven and John
goes um to Steven Seagal like he doesn't
even know him he goes so is all that
stuff real can you really use that and
say God
goes like this he goes
he literally goes
and John goes guess what he goes
and he couldn't really see like that and
he goes you tell me and walked away but
that was it
that was all that real the [__] yeah
question did he ask it as Juanita his
old neighbor
like a hates character work I know
but Steven seagull please do not do the
lady who worked at the bodega on your
corner anymore
[Laughter]
I get what it was like in the Bronx back
then enough
did I see one more set with outside
hanging laundry from building to
building
didn't he get some [__] for uh human
trafficking as a cop in Louisiana he got
into a lot of [__] for a lot of things I
mean Penthouse you know he's like a
legit cop in Louisiana and got busted
for like sex trafficking
yeah I did a movie with his ex-wife I
did a movie with somebody Kelly LeBrock
yes I did a movie with a a TV show she
seemed to be a little screwy though too
now well the stories the stories are
pretty not so good it's a stupid good
guy so it says Steven Seagal the action
movie star a long time ago used one
woman as a sex toy and kept others who
were on call 24 hours a day that makes
sense
didn't get arrested for that
um the Stephen scroll accused of sex
trafficking click on that he's not a
good guy man from what I've heard I
don't know but he's just they're
watching he's going to arrest him for
being awesome
is that a crime in this town now
Vietnamese girl
oh that's never gonna Around the Clock
booty call position this one he's a cop
too
yeah he's he was Bad Lieutenant the
whole time yeah that's what he is show
me your ass yeah how do you suck dick
she says she found two young female
russian attendants who are on call for
cigar sexual needs 24 7. I think Playboy
or Penthouse wrote an article about him
and the article was like crazy where his
maid said he picked me up and and and
basically raped me on on top of a
washing machine then just walked away
like there's there are the accusations
were crazy where you're like whoa well
that's the reason he lives in Russia
isn't it I know you bust for this yes
and I was like you know what Russia's me
too movement isn't that robust I don't
know if you guys know that you guys dip
out different places didn't Gary gluten
Gary Glitter just got out of Vietnamese
jail I think for serving the tiny
sentence they gave him as the guy does
you know rock and roll part Tunes in
every Arena I don't know in him yeah is
he the child uh yeah he's a pedophile
yeah what went over to uh say well he's
going over to Vietnam they ended up
getting him there though too yeah and
they gave him like a slap on the wrist
out there I think it wasn't anywhere
near what would have happened here he is
a [__] boy if I was a research
pedophiles he would be the first one
that popped I'll cut that guy's head off
right now
look at him oh dude I watch it's a shame
I watch so many of those
um pedophile Hunters the online ones oh
that I love them well it's dads against
predators those are the ones that try to
fight people
don't see the one where the Guy meets
The he's he's he meets the father's 12
year old daughter gets uh catfished by
this guy and he had he takes it over and
goes come meet me guy shows up and the
father lets his kind of corso and German
Shepherd kill sound the guy no but the
dogs are biting him they're just like
get him get him that's the dad's gonna
spiders please please don't please you
know and I don't know if that's dead
against Predator no this might be on
this is our YouTube because I know
YouTube was like uh either uh demonetize
them they're doing something because
they were like yeah they're all going to
rumble yeah uh I watched one that was uh
it was like young kids like 19 years old
doing it and I've never seen it done
like
smash style you know I mean like yo yeah
I got you you know we're about to go get
this predator and this thing and they
got him and they're like yo you're gross
bro you're gross and then the guy was
like how old are you and he's like 19
and then the guy's fighting him he's
like whoa you dude I'm getting I'm
fighting a predator like it's the whole
time he's just like it's real for sure
but it's so weird because they said they
were the cops afterwards and [__] but
the problem with a lot of them is
um they're catching
borderline if not very [__] people
who were gonna answer that call if it
was
an 85 year old or a seven-year-old yeah
they can't believe it's happening it's
not really this isn't going to come up
in his life ever again you know I mean
but now they also do catch like pieces
of [__] but I heard they can't do much
like the cops can't do much when like
the when they give her their information
Kick-Ass superheroes they don't know
what they're doing no they can't do like
you want to catch Predator like these
guys in this one that's why they stopped
shooting oh because you don't you
haven't done anything you've just you've
just got it yeah it's I guess I don't
know if intended it'll definitely be
hard to get a job after that yeah you're
still getting exposed for being in a
pretty creepy situation
sheriffs they caught I went on one with
the guy with the big guy with the beard
who does it but we didn't oh we didn't
get anybody we got next to the guy it
was the most insane things happening at
once
like when it all started happening it
started happening very quickly it was
like we meet at this Walmart where they
do it at standing in Texas and uh we go
in he's I meet him in the section we're
talking about it it's funny I was doing
the same walk that they have people do
to catch them I think when I go up there
he goes uh hey you piece of [__]
but uh we were talking he goes yeah the
person is not
he keeps sending pictures of he's
outside but he can't he's not coming in
or something so we got to go out then we
go and
we think from the picture he took we see
the car that's him so we pull up behind
him and they go and like Circle the car
and then they open then they come back
to the car they go it's not him and he's
like he did to the wrong car hey you
hear the [__] a little child oh okay my
apology sir yeah wrong cars so we end up
just pulling up next to the guy and it
was the guy when he just looked over and
saw like four Dudes he was out his boys
are huge uh he [__] took off and I
watched the guy so the the only
interesting thing of it or the most
interesting thing I should say about the
whole thing was I don't know if I've
ever seen anybody like run for their
life before like a genuine like if I
don't terrify my life's over if this
comes out and he was even like 70 in a
hitting like those speed bumps in an old
car doors are gonna fall if those doors
would have fallen off he would just ran
over the engine and just kept going in
the highway traffic he was out he was
out but when we were he was doing like
the going around like a nut we were kind
of following him for a minute and then
all of a sudden like these five black
women I mean unrelated to anything
they're outside of their like like a
navigator or something they're all
wearing see-through clothes to the nips
or like little like g strings and
they're all like just down like twerking
and doing it's morbidly obese each one
more than the next it was what but every
time we're like following this guy and
turning like that Loop of like you know
the traffic lines yeah she's like he
goes we're coming back around the uh fat
black chick scanner they never broke
stride there's a pedophile Chase going
on while they're over there [__] uh
clapping cheeks they were the they were
the mood music
dads catch up to them legally they can't
like [__] them up right or they like
shut the camera against predators oh no
one they just fled out he just says that
the guy goes like square up one-on-one
and they do they fight and it's also he
doesn't do that good in the fight you're
like I mean if you're gonna fight these
Predators be a better fighter yeah let's
take some training you get beat up by
just one of those guys that go with this
actually was the first time I saw this
too there's a girl who does it in
Courtney Elizabeth
and uh she's uh I guess in her 20s or
something
and uh she she for the first time she
always gives like a long
uh intro to what they're getting ready
to do and or the person they caught
and I'd never seen this on a pedophile
outside of their own merch and things
like that a lot of them have merch I've
never seen that she goes and uh and so
he said he was gonna have sex with her
and lured her out and uh said you know
it shows the thing I'm gonna come all in
your face and all this like Terrible
Horrible [__] to a child then she goes
also before we get to Robert I just want
to say the new live free app has been
I've lost 12 pounds already doing
workouts in the middle of it and then
she goes you can't and it shows the
clips of like the you get a personalized
trainer for you it goes great with the
gym or if you're just doing at home body
weight stuff and so it's really been
great for me and I hope you guys check
them out real big and now let's go get
Robert now let's go you're meeting
by the way is an old man who is [__]
and the dads against predators guy goes
with her
like to help on this one and he's just
again his energy doesn't match the
situation all the time this guy's like I
don't know I won't do it again and
they're like what do you mean he won't
do it again dude do it again if you live
in a nursing home right anything I won't
do anything he goes what's that
[__] it's just too much like
what's up dude what's up [__]
yeah he's like too much of that he's
like oh you're not into fighting guys
some somehow you kind of have sympathy
for a pedophile like the show sucks now
it's like wait a minute not meeting me
root for them but I mean some of them
are just classic yeah give me room for a
pedophile
when we first became friends a billion
years ago in Philly I started doing I
love that this makes me laugh so hard we
saw American History X together and he's
right there's a scene in that movie I've
talked about something that makes no
sense they one of the black and white
flashbacks to when he was still a
skinhead
um the movie's about him like reforming
from being a skinhead the flashbacks
they show uh black guys and white guys
arguing at the basketball court and then
he goes all right well [__] let's play
for the courts then Black's first wise
we play for the courts whoever wins
whoever loses leads so can't come to the
Venice courts anymore
not only do the white supremacist beat
these guys which is not going to happen
it ends with a steal and uh and Edward
Norton doing a reverse double-handed
and they play and is that true I don't
remember that yeah
on YouTube
they cheer they cheers and they go damn
it and the music's big and Kurt just
goes are they trying to trick me to
rooting for the for the Nazi guy like
it's such a weird yeah
and he's really good look at him I mean
he's running them that guy's muscular
now I know the big last ball the steel
steel look at this dumb
yeah finally type people win a game of
basketball against black people it's a
problem
yeah but it was white supremacist you go
hey you gotta take me to get right who
knows all white
yeah we throw Kurt Rambis out there
he's not showing up for a Rachel turf
war game Rachel
Gonzaga vs Miami yeah exactly so it's
going to tricking you and like rooting
for the wrong thing the the I always
tell people if you could find Predator
Jamie is the best of those things
because uh like for anyone listening at
home it's just a guy a morbidly obese
guy you do feel bad for a game because
this was never going to happen for him
ever yeah he lives in a room in his
mom's house and he's morbidly obese he's
just his mom is just hilarious because
she's there for the entire confrontation
and she just keeps going like they'll be
like well you said here that you want to
like uh suck her little eight-year-old
[__] and she'll be like Jamie
oh oh
oh
[__] Jamie so a fourth year ago she goes
they don't even have their periods yet I
know that but she's just like she never
breaks
you're a perverty
check you creepy pervert and then by the
way are they also they're always so like
you know [__] also they don't know
like the actual
reality of like what's happening do you
think he's actually [__] though yeah
you're definitely like yeah they're
definitely challenged because I'm
telling you this this lady
goes uh when they're going through that
she goes and he was planning to meet her
at you know this decoy at his work and
stuff like that and she goes that's it
don't worry I'm taking his phone
[Laughter]
no
that's it yeah I'm taking the phone he
goes I think it's bigger than that right
now
there's guys sitting in your living room
[__] disaster
the people that search yeah I have a
daughter yeah oh she's 20. there's still
there's still no one better than the
king of uh
Chris Hansen because I think they have
some compilations of it that you could
watch of his like he got so
like jazz with it by the end yeah you
know what he's doing that his entrance
was always kill he would like wait for
them to say something you know they'd be
like I'll be right down he goes he goes
uh I can't wait to hug your body and he
pops out and be like I'd like to have my
body hugged Frank would you like to hug
my body why don't you have a seat it is
little whatever the thing was first it
started asking I mean always
because I've been thinking about you all
day because have you been thinking about
me Tom I'd like you to think about me
why don't you have a seat
why don't you suck my dick yeah yeah
yeah sometimes they fall to their knees
I'd like to have my [__] until I
screamed would you like to eat my [__]
until I scream why don't you ever see
Ralphs
my thing is the YouTubers that do this
it's like it's one of two things either
gonna start looking for those pedophiles
or they're hunting ghosts like there's
no in between it's either let's hunt
ghosts oh it's completely same kind of
the guy the guy who kept getting in
trouble was the guy who makes them like
do
like stuff like he would make them and
it was it started off so dumb that I
think he thought he had to ramp it up
because you're almost like
if you can have the guy call his family
whatever and do that [__] I guess fine
but he would only explain push-ups yes
push-ups run up and down the block how
did burpees [__] suicide anyone realize
me tell him to run up and down the block
when you tell them to run the blog so
you better come back too man don't just
keep running
he just sends him a run away
uh
the
Hudson the Hudson River and he couldn't
swim so he had to be rescued from the
Hudson and he got canceled yeah but
again it was like a thing and this I'm
not justifying any of these pedophiles
that one was like a 21 year old guy who
was there to meet like a 16 year old
like boy yeah for uh like I'm like
almost and again I might be wrong and
gay people feel free to just tell me I'm
completely wrong with this I think
that's just what happens by the way I
think a young 20-something [__] a
teenage boy I've heard gay people say
that on shows they say 100 they go well
the big secret is that there are 15 16
17 year old boys that go to those clubs
that get online and and well they say
it's because they don't have anyone
their own age to kind of relate to it or
it's just that they want to [__] a guy
and they want to stay in the closet or
remember we're just like what can you
tell me how did you do that you know
they just get wrapped up in the world
let me tell you something when we were
15 and 16 17
if you told me I could get on an app and
[__] a 25 year old 10 I'm getting on the
app and having sex with that 25 year old
don't worry about me every Friday
Saturday night at 16 years old I'll be
fine yeah damn that's confident I'm
gonna be like I don't want this old lady
to see my little weenie
I was building a runaway I would have
given hit the old College try yeah if it
was big we was there if they were into
me which is what older guys are into
twinks did you guys have any I am blown
away by that so my I'm the one of my
only friends in the world who has no in
his life knowledge of a
one of the Buddies [__] uh someone
another Buddy's mom or the teacher
[__] us I had none of that my
teachers were all old ugly women I would
say that too or uh maybe the guys got
some air it's a very rare thing I don't
know it was always a family I'll I'll
read New York Post every morning and be
like you know teacher gets busted I'm
like Who's hotter than that hot ass
teacher yeah my teacher had cancer over
nose and had a fake nose at all times
yeah yeah I don't we had Mrs Jaya Ramen
uh a lady who smelled like her name yeah
teaching chemistry yeah none of my
teachers were [__] yeah I didn't I
wasn't one
so when I went to school I switched
schools in senior year and went to like
not
like an intramural prison that I went to
in Philly I went to an actual place and
I would say maybe like the
like the because then there was coaches
for actual teams and those guys taught
like social studies and stuff so maybe
like the girls had crushes on the gun
yeah but I couldn't remember my
wrestling coach like a lot of the
seniors in high school were obsessed
with them he was like 33 but he was
always the coaches it was always the
coach though because my in high schools
the men's or the women's lacrosse coach
he was yeah it must have been
24-25 and there was like so many rumors
he was [__] like a ton well we should
just almost take away after all those
gymnastics documentaries I watched like
can't girls just train girls like it's
like I don't know why if you want to be
the best of me you have to send your
child away for four months with an old
Russian man he's probably gonna touch
her [__] it's what you're lining up
for it's where you're lying up well
looking back I went to boarding school
and the teachers there they were
everybody lived on the same campus so I
think the art teacher looking back was
probably hooking up with my friend when
she was a senior I'm pretty sure though
but she was 18. he was probably 30
something and that was in 1985. let me
tell you what was acceptable that [__]
you would go to Europe and you would see
I'm telling you on the beaches you'd see
a 15 year old girl with a 25 year old
guy and it was just like I don't know
how deep into the 20s but I remember
like
the heart
girls in my like senior year maybe even
junior year were dating guys who were
like 23 years almost all of them yeah if
they were like and there's guys you
never and they drive them everywhere we
all couldn't but now now if you're Leo
DiCaprio and you're 50 and you're dating
a 23 year old they they you hear about
it it's like it's a it's considered
um I guess now almost predatory I just
see I don't consider it to be predatory
what I'm more taken back by it is like
I'm not talking about like a 23 year old
who thinks you're hot showing up and
[__] in the middle of the night
and maybe hang out for like dinner or
something
but 23 especially when he's 50 is that
right yeah it's just like you're doing
it's like stop pretending there's
anything else but [__]
it's because you have a daughter too
yeah like when you have a daughter you
realize every bit of their age they are
my daughter's 20. and I would say she's
like
younger almost you know what I mean that
she's probably more experienced that I'm
aware of and stuff but she's a good kid
which is right 15 year old but you put
their kid but I mean they're they're
[__] exactly
same [__] where you're like no I know
how young she is and her I like I
understand like that you know she's 15
mental it's a mental thing and and the
other thing is that she has a boyfriend
now and it's it's beautiful yeah it's
beautiful to watch He's Asian I know I
know Brian's on he's 27. yeah but you
can see if there's a sick ride
he holds myth foreign my son who's 11 is
such a smart ass I go who is he my son
goes he's 28.
but he's uh he's 15 but there's that
innocence man my daughter's a smart girl
and blah blah old soul blah blah
whatever you want to say
yeah oh dude the world's you're delicate
too in that stage so if you told me that
she was dating a 20 year old it's going
to be a problem for me because I'm going
to [__] stop that immediately
it's like they're gonna take you to do
things that's right forget the [__]
that's right they're just gonna take you
to do things that you're probably really
not ready and they're gonna break your
heart they're probably going to break
another 18 uh you know a party of all 18
year olds and you're gonna feel weird
and yeah
all that pressure but so it goes I mean
it's kind of like how you learn too I
mean that's how all of us
my daughter's senior year was online so
no problem
thanks Kobe
yeah man having a daughter is is uh I
worry more about my son it's like you
know you'll deal with it just I really I
know it really is that way but also what
you'll see is as your daughter gets
older too
and I don't I don't know if I describe
this live but I said it a few times
she's already done things that I'm like
she's got tattoos you know what I mean
like uh
I think the way she wears her makeup is
ridiculous to me yeah you know what I
mean she doesn't dress like [__] or
anything but like she's
what's her style it's like it's almost
like yeah kind of like new medley that
kind of thing she's got into like that's
better than [__] no for sure yeah but
um she but she's you know she's 20 also
and I'm sure wants to be sexy in her way
or however like young she seems to me
but like um
yeah it was like dating like she's told
me nothing about it all and do you want
to know though no I have trouble with it
dude
love her she'll tell me she's going to
an underground party that breaks up when
Cops show up and then if I go
can you call me when you get home please
or let me know if you need an Uber from
there or something she'll go yeah and
she's like if it's four in the morning
she calls and says like hey I'm home
yeah that's like I need not going to ask
for you yeah like that's what I'm saying
that's why I lost my train of thought as
they do whatever these things are
you'll get over them
[__] trying drugs drinking all those
things because
what it is like when the next day
when you realize you're like oh they're
still the same person you know I mean
it's like it's like it's not a different
person because this thing happened like
that's what it is I was like I know her
so she did this thing but like I don't
think this thing is like I just don't
want to hear about it my ex gave my
as well yeah because she's with this guy
now he's 15 and they spend time together
you have to have that talk right I can't
be involved in that [__] I I'm I can't
be involved it's my daughter so I just
my buddy was walking by his 14 year old
daughter's room
he told me he goes he's walking by his
14 year old daughter's room and his
daughter
he hears his daughter go I gave him a
[__] oh [__] because I gave him
upload that was but we didn't have we
didn't do anything else but like the
Kool-Aid man be like [__] yeah he just
said he said I felt like somebody stuck
something like a spike in my back I went
ah like my back ah like when you you
know when in the Super Bowl when when
they pour the Gatorade
he just went [__] and he stopped like
that he goes and he just went and his
arms died he just went oh I would I had
to walk away he's like that's life what
am I gonna do well that's like bro it's
different right like Rogan's bit on
probably two or three spots ago he goes
I think he was talking about Harvey
Weinstein stuff he goes like if I had a
son and you know and he came or if I had
a daughter and she's like yeah however
he wants you want to put me in Batman
but I just you know [__] him he'd be
like I'd [__] kill him if my son was
like Hey Dad everyone's doing stuff like
[__] I'm gonna be Batman but holy [__]
give me back Harvey was a woman holy
[__] you're gonna be Batman yeah I
probably think it was Harvey
like my daughter raising a daughter I
can't they got they got to a point about
11 where I couldn't I couldn't really
discipline her like I certainly can't
hit her I certainly can't do much she
would there was an emotional
um there was an emotional space I had to
negotiate my son he's 11. I can threaten
that [__] sure
yeah it's like you're a boy so I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna get into an
emotional
damages yeah exactly you know what I
mean like [__] what do you like hey
dude I'm the real world get the [__]
over there who's the discipline one in
the family do like do you are you the
strict dad oh it had to be me well it's
funny now probably more the phone
because now she's like 20.
let's go see the Deftones tonight you
know I mean like you can go to concerts
and how did you discipline did you have
to discipline her or was it your was it
your her mom's yeah so it's [__] no
her mom are you still with the moment
okay the worst was uh I hated that
because when I was on the road I know
she wants to be a part of disciplining
too but on the road you guys know when
that phone call I mean every weekend I
felt like it was like tell your daughter
that she has to but I'm like no I would
never do this to you yeah like when I
have her and she does something wrong
like I just deal with handle you know
what I mean like so I think she wanted
me to be the more but I don't know I
didn't like uh cause any like
major issues are going to be having to
be like the you know the your punished
one you guys got along very well always
yeah yeah it was uh yeah me and her have
always yeah did she have any boyfriends
that you didn't approve of no boyfriends
as far as I know I keep and her mom both
keep thinking that there's outside shots
this kid's a lesbian
she hangs out with her friends very
close with her friends to that kind of
thing like you know her roommate is like
coming if she comes for dinner she comes
for dinner the roommate comes for dinner
too but then they stay at another
friend's house out there which was uh
and if it was the last friend I met all
right Isabella
especially their mom or mom goes because
I think sometimes she's dating that girl
I go nice
decent hell yeah kid good for sure yeah
I'm like get him kid but uh I don't know
I said I know she just keeps it for me
because like your dad she's also just
been like
in in such a a major part of like comedy
growing up and she's been really good
with that well we found out you know I
mean like me telling her like I mean the
stuff I did on Netflix was like I had to
call her and be like I'm so sorry I
really want to say this yeah and she's
like yeah I get it yeah I hear your
material he and I found out recently
that somebody we know was uh banging
guys
it was the last thing we expected I just
found out that he was out there trolling
and banging girls but banging guys and
said uh but it almost had like a coming
out of it like no no no no that's still
being found out yeah yeah very
surprising we're like wow it's uh all
right when you think about not that
surprise not a surprise if we just go
back through the memories you're like oh
yeah a lot of it is very strange that's
how I thought about uh
that was hilarious like Paul Mooney I
think it was it was gay but that was one
of the funniest like I remember standing
outside of Caroline just when I heard
that situation
oh I know what it was I I had to cover
for him
for a long time on stage because I think
when the show started he was in the air
still on an airplane oh my God and they
called me at home and they were like
we're running out of community you come
over and Caroline's and like do some
time so I did some time after the show
and before he went on they were like hey
this is Jay he just did a bunch of time
I wasn't asking for anything from it I
was like hey Paul Mooney and he was like
he was just kind of shitty to me yeah I
closed the door of the green room and I
went upstairs and someone goes like ah
he's just like a [__] gay guy I go
[__] what do you mean they go yeah Paul
Mooney's like yeah you didn't know he's
gay ago Paul Mooney's guy look like I
look out of the corner of my eyes like
his head shot he's got like Circle
sunglasses and a hat that's tied under
his chin I go oh man am I an
idiotics
oh oh yeah well he he um Paul Mooney uh
Jamie Masada told me an interesting
story so Paul Mooney when he was making
it and famous he bought a Rolls-Royce uh
it might have been a Mercedes something
very expensive car
and uh
Jamie got in the car with him he said I
got to go to the certain area but you
got to come with me because otherwise
you know I'm gonna get stopped and Jamie
was like what are you talking about is
the 70s Jamie said that they got they
they had to go I think through Beverly
Hills Jamie said they got stopped like
four times because he was a black man
driving Rolls Royce and they had to get
out on the curb sit on the curb go
through all the [__] and Jamie was right
there Jamie was like that's kind of so
he Paul came up in an actually very
racist world oh sure you know and so for
him it was like let's do with him being
gay well just being [__] I think he
just especially to people that's all the
gay part
he can't be positive too in the gay
community and the black community too
you couldn't be gay yeah and make money
thanks for going on stage you white
[__] yeah so you know what I
mean like you blew my granddaddy down
the street with a fire hose I didn't
mean
one of the funniest
things ever I'll always say on leeching
the skanks like the the epitome of what
the show is like can you make the funny
out of the awful yeah without having to
go this was awful and this you know it
was uh
the video of black people getting blown
down the street with fire hoses and then
we go but
put the song Wipeout over it and I'm
telling you it's a different video
it's a different video
it looks like everyone's having a blast
look at people want to run into it and
go like me
[Laughter]
that's the end of our show forever this
has been our last show thanks so much we
can all acknowledge black people being
blown on the street with fire hoses is a
horrible time that thank God is gone yep
thank God what a horrible is there a
butt there but a video of it
with the one song Wipeout playing over
it it's a good home game
once again guys thanks so much for
tuning in
our career we'll be leaving and you
won't find us anywhere Holocaust West
Virginia uh Holocaust body dumps with
Closing Time by Semisonic now that
that's we didn't do that one
but you know what
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here
I know
who started uh legionist gangs give me
the origin story Allegiance games
I was sort of when podcasts were just
you know like uh I think WTF was like
popping at that point Corolla they said
what year is this
two thousand eleven eleven 2011 and we
uh
I keep a Lewis and Dave were just my but
it's so funny we've been talking on the
podcast lately about this the
perspective differences of people and
friendships
it always looked to everybody like I was
I was always kind of like hanging out
with the comics who were like above me
wise I was brought in by Keith Robinson
to be around and I was around Patrice
and Keith Robinson and uh and Colin
Quinn and all those guys every night you
know that's amazing Comics Bobby Kelly
uh but they weren't like my day-to-day
friends they were older than me they
were doing so my friends were my friends
I had my contemporaries and then also
just some people Comics who were younger
than me
but they just made me laugh there are
people I got along with and Lewis and
Dave were two of those people
and as our friendship went on though it
was so funny to hear them recount the
stories and they go
yeah when you were broke and uh you know
but we thought you were like you know
because you were working in the clubs we
thought you were money and you were
running a karaoke night at the
the what's now the village underground
you're running a karaoke night to make
the 200 a night you needed doing it and
he goes we would just sit there at your
feet at the DJ booth and like stare but
our more successful friend Jay doing a
shitty job and he's like we were like
[__] and I was like oh like I just
looked at it I was like my buddies were
coming to keep me company yeah I'm like
yeah we have some free drinks everyone
hangs out and parties but I get it also
because they were they'd walk around
because
the comics would know me at the comedy
cell and knew them as like my God yeah
yeah and then they start you know people
were shitties are stuck going like
where's your [__] and [__] like that
you're like hey hey
but so that wasn't the case they were
just the guys that like on a day-to-day
basis like we could just hang and laugh
Dalia used to that with his friends
Delia would see people there and he'd go
he'd have his group of his men his
minions and he'd go like this he'd go
hey um three guys who could be in any
movie in the background uh
yeah David he's he's just I was DM him
probably his first appearance on road
I'm like you're [__] smart man oh
yeah but it was funny but but it's great
to see where everyone's at too like Dave
was essentially a guy on the couch at my
house which I loved it was like me and
Dave just hung everything in a smoked
pot we would not smoke pot for a couple
hours when we got my daughter from
school like probably people thought we
were a gay couple picking her up yeah
let me go back and play video games with
my daughter and do whatever he got
really into politics he's running for
office isn't he no okay thank God okay
he would have ruined did you hear that I
heard I heard he was like thinking I'm
thinking about it for sure was he really
yeah he's wicked really smart yeah he's
insanely smart when he breaks it down
because like if I was into it I would
break it down like he does it like makes
sense to me oh yeah yeah like when
Jordan Peterson talks or some of these
other political guys like [__] sakes
breaks it down phenomenal and he's found
that lame which is amazing form and he's
so great at it but the it was when all
those podcasts were just starting
I was like I guess I don't know because
again I was kind of fledged I did like a
half hour special and I did the jfls and
all that stuff nothing was really kind
of popping
so I was like I guess I'll start a
podcast like everybody in the first
episode we ever have is kind of a fun
one because it's essentially
gonna be
like my podcast and like my boys will be
on it with me and it's kind of starting
to think of a first episode just trying
to think of a name for it and everything
and and going through that but it was
really good that was going to be the
energy it was gonna be is it you Lewis
and Dave it's me Lewis and Dave here
from the beginning and then it just so
quickly became it's a three-person
dynamic it's not like and my name and
also they realize quickly my name
doesn't really do anything for it at
that time anyway you know I mean again
it's like the looking up to the person
chemistry man you guys have good
chemistry but it's also like knowing
like the
like like again the perspective the
perspective of level versus the level
you're actually yeah yeah because again
I remember when I was just doing open
mics in Philadelphia at the black comedy
club Eddie iift came in and did a uh a
weekend there I think he was featuring
for somebody
but I was talking to a white guy who was
a New York Comic in this uh black comedy
club that I started at
and uh he was then I'm asking about New
York and I mean the things he's saying
are like the most rudimentary level of
things you hope to get going in New York
but he was telling me I was like he was
like yeah you pop over like dangerfields
for like that's like a half hour spot to
give you and that's like 25 bucks and
then uh you go over to the this club
that's 30 bucks you get to do 15 minutes
over there swing it on down in the
comedy cell or after midnight and then
you go on it's called a food spot where
like uh if you go on uh sometime
whatever you want to eat
on the house from the club and I was
like wow you're living it I'm like even
your meal every night you're funny for
your meals it's so romantic and awesome
and then you realize it's like when I
was doing food spots I was like why did
I just give me the 30 bucks I don't want
the Middle Eastern food 100 waffle right
next door yeah yeah you know what give
me 10 less dollars and I'm allowed to
have in food that's what I love about
New York though man you can do a lot of
spots in in within a cab ride you know
you can do oh no it's great Caroline's
closed gone damn yeah it's done
absolutely that was such an institution
Caroline's is gone yeah what else I
popped on stage with the tell like one
of his last nights I did Sony Hall uh
last time I was there two weeks ago have
you ever done Sony hauls no it's new
it's a theater but it's a great theater
man didn't that tell close out
Caroline's or was it uh he did the last
headliner and then there was a New
Year's Eve who owns Caroline
it was Caroline he's a red robin stand
up really no I'm just stand up New York
still around stay in your store around I
went up there for the first time in
years the other day it's Kerry Hoffman
still running it no no he sold it to two
uh Jewish Brothers
what about what about uh and then
Gotham's not a headliner Club anymore
yeah no I'm not allowed in the comic
strip why why I started they they me too
it was actually where I met my ex-wife
it's the reason my daughter's alive our
baby shower's day yeah that's where I
started it started to become like they
just you know when Lucian the old old
Booker died it was kept alive with like
good Comics still kind of coming through
but it became
for a club that was just great because
it was low turnover with the uh with the
staff the staff was like a family it's
one of those clubs yeah yeah and then
sort of become a money thing then they
stopped getting rid of it did you know
Lucian yeah yeah well he got me he was
the one who would put me up at the 840
spot every night yeah on a Monday he'd
be like you open it Brian you know I've
got oh you've got a lot of energy very
talented but you need to really cut your
teeth on you need to do it this way he
was such an interesting I was with him
the week before he died he had
Scleroderma and so these fingers were
falling off so they don't let you in
just because well no so it was
kind of going the [__] for years it
seemed so like we
like I just kind of wasn't working there
I just didn't need to anymore for the
money so much and I was like you know
once in a while but I would do it once
in a while I'd be like I'd pick two
clubs and I'd go back and forth for the
night and on this night
I was uh going up to the to the second
of three shows at the strip that night
you see what I mean and uh you could do
you do it for a show then you do the
second show in the third show yeah so
I'm going
I go up there and I'm like watching
before I go on William Stevenson the
late William Stevenson who passed away a
couple years ago now was up there looks
like Cleveland
from The Cleveland Show Cleveland
William the black guy yeah yeah oh he
died yeah
a couple years back now but William was
like just like a a house host like he
was just like a guy yeah man I love I
loved William and he's like an old
chubby man yeah damn it and so he was on
saying he would go up there and he would
fight with us now this audience like
they've started relying on like the
people in Times Square like you want to
see comedy this club that club cocaine
marijuana like just those people are
selling tickets so it's it became like a
a a a Puerto Rican uh family reunion at
everything it was like groups of 30 yeah
that don't want to yeah like listen to
uh
it was just combative and William
Stevens is just an older guy didn't give
a [__] and he'd be like shut up [__] or
whatever he was funny Williams the first
thing they're they're going at him and
like it was just I went on stage and
they were still like the whole set was
like
having like navigate them you know I
mean talk to them and stuff when I got
off I remember saying to my girlfriend I
was like I think you just may have seen
the second the last spot I do at the
comic strip
and then she was like really I was like
yeah that's just not fun like it's just
weird and when I went up for that last
spot afterwards I get in there William
Stevenson's on stage
yeah I wanted somebody for putting their
feet on the stage and calling some lady
a [__] and her 30 year old boyfriend or
whatever jumps up on stage and gets like
in William's face
and I was like uh I I was like I was
like oh boy I wasn't didn't think he was
going to hit him before I was like this
place notoriously had security always
you know what I mean yeah oh man like
this is gonna be there's no security
doing nothing there's no one there to
help the situate so I go on stage and
just get the guy off stage and kind of
push him off and like you know he's like
see outside type sure whatever so we and
calm down and William uh after that
night I was like Jesus Christ that's
crazy crazy that that's went down there
the next day on Facebook I think it was
William wrote they fired me at the comic
strip for the rest from like you know
for working there for a while or the
rest of the weekend at least and he was
like I'm not telling anybody what to do
but that club sucks and the shitty thing
to do or whatever
but um
so I just wrote back to him on the
Facebook I go yeah I'm not even putting
in there anymore dude that's become
chaos over there
and then um
the owner who's passed away now too
Richie tinkin
and I think it was his wacky wife he's
like married like an old a waitress who
used to work there years ago and I think
she was [__] somebody else who works
there on some sort of an agreement the
whole thing is a wacky situation and he
was just this old decrepit guy and
um when I put that thing up there they
started going on the social media tirade
against me and like putting this crazy
[__] up on like it was on Twitter it was
like uh you defended somebody who called
a woman a [__] and that's a word and
well it's this crazy long thing going on
and I'm like you're out of your mind
and then he wrote at one point they were
so easy to write back to because he was
like
Eddie Murphy Ray Romano Chris Rock I
forgive the fourth person he named four
people he goes Jerry Seinfeld these
people have never ever had to use the
word [__] in their life on or off stage
and I'm like that's a crazy statement to
make that's a crazy statement oh first
of all it's definitely not true that
could have picked a better four people
if you want to try that one you know
what I mean
oh good burn good Burn yeah he writes
that and then uh
so when he kept like going was like kind
of Slam Campaign Of Me
uh he removed it all because I put up a
thing that I always found funny about
the comic strip
was that Richie tinkin was also Eddie
Murphy's manager for a long time
in his early years particularly and they
have two plaques on the wall of gold
albums it's comedian and whatever the
one after that was and both of them have
tracks that say one says [__] and the
other album has one says [__]
parentheses Revisited
and I just wrote that I know do you
worry about taking those down ever are
you only worried about like upsetting
[__] or whatever and then they they
took all their stuff down but it was
definitely like yeah you're not welcome
in here anymore like get ready whatever
yeah it's exactly it's like I don't know
what to do and I walked by it and it was
because it was my home club and after
you know 10 years later 15 years later I
walked by it it was just depressing
nothing it looks calcified the greatest
one of the greatest
like plateaus to hit or just levels
rather in comedy I think is not the the
local comedy club politics meaning
nothing too that's such a liberating
thing because when it means everything
to you A lot of them sort of abuse it it
affects you don't like [__] but also
just like they know they can treat that
they know they can treat you I never got
involved in that I think part of it was
I've been called by clubs that are you
know when you make uh thirty dollars a
show from each of these clubs and one's
telling you yeah you can't work that
other one if you're gonna be like come
on man it's not my audience who's
showing up but we're just doing
showcases does Al what's his name I
don't know Martin yeah does he still own
New York comedy club he might oh I think
he might own Broadway Comedy Club the
one still up in the middle town but New
York comedy podcast
do you know Michaels no but I will say
the uh as guy Emilio who manages Krista
Stefano and stuff Emilio uh bought the
New York Comedy Club location oh sick
and he's franchise him around he's done
a pretty good job okay he's killing it
for Christmas I did Nyack
that's good I'm doing like in a few
weeks I like the staff I like I like the
staff yeah we're gonna see how that go
that's one of those weird like yeah
theater clubs yeah it's a weird market
and you're like ah man yeah sort of near
New York yeah but it's small people
we'll see it's depressing on traffic all
right Jim what do you got
all right first one
is this video I just saw if this is in
California
you guys perform your chest with the
four right would you say you guys were
performed by chance Chatsworth is where
all the porn shot and keep going okay I
thought you guys had a club there or
something anymore no not Chatsworth no
excuse me so basically a school set a
pickup truck's tire came off one of the
lugs was messed up and then it went in
front of a Kia and I'll just play this
for you dude I was driving the highway
today thinking about this it's just a
trapped out it's just a tire that keeps
stressed out
and someone could hit you after you
there's so many things that could have
went wrong but they're fine minor
injuries apparently Jesus
yep bring it again let's see
it's just launched okay
um I do remember her when she was so
beautiful
well she said when you say well
he's saying
defined aging beautiful yes
yeah what else you got yeah absolutely
next video
absolutely wow what a scratchy
she's in a town where everybody doesn't
let that happen she's in a town but she
was also known for her beauty like
everyone had a crush on her back she's
also 50 she's 60 years
whatever that documentary yeah
she's a year older than I am so that's
what happens that's why you know we have
technology that pulls your face back she
says she thinks about it but she won't
uh it's a really quick props to Brennan
I can't believe this happened it was
super cool he actually bought his
mother-in-law a freaking house this is
wow yeah
not too many people know this but for
the last five years your boy has been
saving every single dime from all my
touring on the road for one reason one
reason only it's a big goal for anybody
whatever you're doing whether an
entertainment podcasting YouTuber
regular gig whatever it is your goal
always is to buy your parents
and kids are going crazy right now my
kids feel absolutely crazy the goal is
only to buy your parents a house well
today all that hard work all those tour
dates all that stuff it's come to
fruition I'm buying my mother-in-law
house she's the best grandma in the
world she has no idea this is happening
she's gonna pull up the house I'm gonna
give her the keys so this is so cool
dude fans have different maintenance
possible buying every single ticket to
all those crazy cities I was in to the
haters do you motivate me more than you
know
your your wife your wife drove her up uh
by father-in-law okay he knew he went
through the process this is so cool she
had an idea
shoot
I'm just saying like Okay
I mean that's yes yeah it's a [__]
house
does she know does she know it's just no
clue yeah she's like I like the
refrigerator door on the left but it's
great it's a little small I always
forget that she's a good looking woman
yeah
it's your house she's a thick girl shirt
oh
that's so cool dude we're being the best
grandma
the key bothered me it was like old
yeah
skeleton key
my son's pretty cool dude yeah yeah so
that's super dope that's awesome yeah I
don't get anything
no there's a guest room please man keep
going they can stay in the guest room
did you ever see uh I thought it was
funny I don't know if it was supposed to
be was a comedian DC Young Fly bought
his mom a house but he got like you know
like a row house and a place there's
like four burners uh like on a basic
level I mean it's awesome listen you buy
somebody a [__] house and it's just
funny usually when that video comes out
it's about like a pretty decked out you
know I mean it's like LeBron James
buying his mama fur car or something
it's never like well that's like the
wrong way yeah I guess he goes yo I just
got you a Buick Enclave but it's rarely
well a Rock when he was like the video
starts kind of like mine to be honest
and he's all you know my my body doubled
my stunt worker he's been with me for 10
years he's broken ribs he broke his back
he's broke both legs and today
I give them a Ford F-150
sponsored by them aren't you spot
a 16 year old son of Maybach that [__]
made me feel bad about I was just like
oh God
yeah for always being you
for Jennifer Lopez's birthday he
released like a thousand doves all right
dude is that it's not about you at all
is it yeah look through social media
[__] you up because you're you know
you're seeing what people do I mean you
know remember that show on MTV uh my
sweet 16. yeah it was like so outlandish
like so ridiculous well it's funny when
you saw they started doing the celebrity
kids because you're like wow apple farms
fall from the tree it was like celo like
sea level yeah
coming in like with a like he's wearing
a dashiki I was like why isn't hologram
Outcast coming to my party
yeah well I have a little bit about how
the Rich and Famous should probably not
have kids because it just ends up being
a disaster yeah it's it's it's hard to
well it's the thing is like you do want
your kids to like have everything better
struggle if they don't have anything to
struggle for I'm watching that well that
is interestingly with my daughter right
now like it's I get it she's 20 and
she's like you know kind of wants to
dick around whatever but like she ain't
no rush you know what I mean she's not
worried she's not an idiot so it's like
she knows she'll like get it she wasn't
like but she didn't feel like yeah I did
say I was like when I was 19 like I knew
I wanted to do this for sure like comedy
you want to get out of the house like I
wanted my Independence yeah yeah yeah
well she's out of the house like she's
got her own place yeah it's just
different yeah yeah but she's like yeah
she's not any kind of major rush to like
figure out
tomorrow's thing I mean you've been
doing comedy for a hot second when she
was younger like really in the like you
know I'd say they'll probably remember
what between like 10 and 14 were you at
the level you're at now where like
everything's all good like your big
Jay's selling out no no she did it's
funny like she's adapted to it well like
she definitely
no I guess she remembers like our broke
years for sure yeah she was definitely
there for the brother that's important
what's funny is how fast she's taken to
not broke years
she'll be weirded out if I was like I
just got some last minute nosebleeds for
this game she'd be like
all right
son I was like what do you want for your
birthday and he didn't have anything he
wanted and I was like
yes I got it that's not good yeah
I gotta do something bad to you now
I gotta send you away or something I
don't know what else you got Jen
all right so Jimmy Garoppolo recently
signed with the Raiders and then the
thing on the headlines is bringing that
sexy to Las Vegas yeah so there's a
brothel in Las Vegas where it said that
brothel is saying if he can get free sex
for life but there's basically these two
girls from this brothel that are saying
he can get free sex for life it's a
chicken ranch that's one of them does he
have to tip though okay oh her name's
Caitlin Bell okay and there's the other
one oh oh well he's fine Alice little
but uh yeah Caitlin Bell's pretty
smoking hot wait which one is that
that's Caitlin Bell the the first one
that was awesome up there yeah but
that's like that's there's like
everything little that one I bet this
one's more fun
uh she shits with the door open yes
this one 30 chance guy
she does have a bit of a masculine they
have a strong face
you go home still with her but like the
whole time you're going like please
don't have a cop pull out here
it's not hard I don't know why yeah
Jimmy garoppolo's probably like all
right guess well you would stay in that
uh porn star uh this is just uh maybe
like what six seven days ago yeah so six
nine at the gym got beat up so you know
he snitched right John so the gangster's
been looking for him apparently he
worked out out at this Planet Fitness
every day for 20 minutes he does the
StairMaster which is why he's skinny fat
right so every he does that every day so
they found out his routine here's the
worst part about all this his shorts
that sucks
dude he got stomped out we got by guys
wearing Crocs it could have been way
worse I didn't even realize everyone is
it also just white guys I thought it was
white guys still couldn't tell I don't
think they're white are they I mean I
thought this guy of some sort those are
Crocs
I know he's dressed like a young Sarah
Silverman we're like he's wearing like
pantyhose under shorts so they just
jumped him in in
the bathroom I did okay with cameras
running though it's such a great thing
with Takashi 69 on like not you know I
knew like the like who he was visually
ultimately my daughter like liked his
music at one point and then she didn't
because whatever the the snitching thing
happened and then they made uh that Hulu
series documentaries three parts
and I watched the first two and while I
don't love the music there's some that I
thought was like pretty cool like what
it is the way like the way you like his
games and [__] yeah
I liked uh and I also dug his thing I
liked he was like it shows he was like a
kid the guy who worked at the bodeg on
his Corner was like uh uh Danny man he
was coming all the time he had this like
weird art artistic ideas for kids you'd
always tell people he's gonna be a
superstar but he made clothing and did
all kinds of things and he would make
videos for a stud he was just finding
his way and I appreciate this guy as an
artist hustle and then it shows him kind
of like come up in the second episode
and I went on Legion of skanks that
night and I was like yo I was like we
I was like we should get takashi69 for a
skank Fest I go that guy's the energy
for sure of skank Fizz wild it's like
uninhibited he goes for it but it's like
cool and it's things like artistic and
he's also like people come at him
and blah blah and then it's
so I'm like we should definitely guys
takashi69 is all right with me and I
went home at night and I watched part
three and it was like he [__] the 13
year old yeah he tied his girlfriend to
a radiator and beat the [__] oh God I
have to wait six days till I get back
home
everyone
for him too I was like this kid's dope
man dude I did that with uh I may have
told you this before bro uh I read Artie
Lang's last book the crash and burn
after he I was working with already a
decent amount of gigs he was taking me
out with him I thought this very big
kinship to him for some reason love his
books love him and I just I think that's
what he does to people he makes you feel
that way you know and I uh
into a few months of like kind of doing
some some dates with them is when he
stabs himself
and I was like and it shook me out and
then he came back and he was sort of
back around and like you know I [__]
him but we never talked about this yes
you know are you okay and everything
he'd say yeah and then the book came out
and I read the book
and one day when taking a [__]
I just got to like
the last like two pages
but I was done whatever happened I had
to go and I was like I'll finish them
next [__]
and I uh put the book down I saw already
that now in that book
early I'm surprised how early IT
addresses it it gets into him it was
like I was he describes the whole story
goes I was out of my mind on drugs
and I was trying to sleep because I
thought like blah blah blah so I that's
why I drank bleach and that was and I
and I try to make myself bleed I was
psychotic I didn't know what I was doing
I was just trying I wasn't trying to
kill myself yeah which made me feel the
thing I felt when he did that I was like
damn I was like working with him a
little bit and like
you know I've read this guy's books
before like maybe something I could have
done maybe to like talk to him or I
don't know it sucked and then I was like
he said he's not trying to kill himself
and I was like well that's actually
relieving so when I saw him I felt
comfortable enough to go
dude I go I'm almost finished the book I
got like three pages left I go uh I
gotta tell you when I read it I
could have been happier to see that like
you weren't trying to kill yourself man
and it was like just like a psychosis
because that's
that really shook me when you did that
he was like yeah because you didn't
finish the book yet I was like nah
there's a few more pages left he's like
well I just stopped there and I was like
that's just where I finished taking a
[__] this morning he was like okay and
his reaction was weird enough that I was
like I should go read those last three
pages I mean right I think the second
the last page he goes also I lied
earlier in this book on the night of
whatever I was trying to end my life in
the most depressing thing I was like
well who puts a head fake in a book it's
the written word it's not spoken where
you change your mind at the end and you
go don't even worry about taking another
chapter out we have a book quote we have
to hit a page quota I'll just say at the
end he goes that chapter was [__] I
was just trying to kill myself
I remember the whole thing I was like oh
thank God he was just trying to sleep by
putting us selling his knife nine times
oh my God I was so sleepy gotta finish
the book gotta finish this surprise
twist ended yes I mean the last page
you're sorry for lying what's he up to
right now I don't know is it cool to
work with
he was great and then it was you know
here's the thing it was great and then
uh first guy ever went on the road with
I was with him a couple times we all you
and him had the same manager at
different points
Ken still in a business
no I think he's just spending the money
he should have been doing when he was
younger just spending the money he got
from what his family or yeah yeah he's
trust fun kid for sure I think Ken truce
was the manager I'll
have no great book him like I'm fine
it's all water under the bridge but when
I fired him he told me I was talentless
and going nowhere because I fired him
okay so that was he got a little
emotional yeah I thought for what it was
and uh you're just like okay but I saw
him uh
so one time we were driving up to
Montreal I think I got new faces also
gave me terrible advice for new faces it
was like old school advice for something
that wasn't happening anymore dress this
way talk about this they want your
sitcom that days were over at that point
but driving up there we stopped at the
outlets or whatever I watched him like
impulse buy like a five six thousand
dollar watch and I was like okay and
we're driving up in a very fancy car
that explains a lot yeah and when
uh I when they did Chappelle Show season
one uh
care Mexico was my roommate and Neil
brandinson Kurt Metzger all the scripts
and I like
threw some little jokes into some of the
things or kirking you know told him that
Jay gave a couple things they gave me a
line in one of the sketches on Chappelle
Show season one four came out you know
like before everyone how big it was
gonna be
and then I got a call the day before
filming saying I've done I've done best
BET's Comic View too many times without
joining the unions like the after and
sag or whatever and then I'd have to pay
to join that before I can go on set
tomorrow and it was twelve hundred
dollars which might as well have been a
bazillion you might as well still make a
fictitious amount of money I'm like on
me
I'm like no I don't have that and I
remember like seeing what I could do or
if I could move it or I remember make
payment also now this is different too I
believe but you could make payments it
was you have to pay this off that's
right and I was like uh [__] but I
remember calling Ken truce and I was
like
hey man you know I watched this guy
spend six grand like I like that watch
yeah I go can you pay this and I'll just
take it out of whatever the next gigs I
do or whatever it is and he was like
it's just
it's like one line on a late night cable
show I just don't think it's worth it
let's wait on the gig like pays for
itself you know and then we'll get you
in the SAG after and I was like really
and he was like yeah I was like you sure
you can't just like I'll get it back to
you in any way I possibly can he was
like yeah
and then it became the Chappelle show
it's awesome then it became it's also
the line where the kid jumps up when
he's blind and black yeah and he calls
the car full of white kids the n-word
and he's like he just calls n words I
would have been like awesome yeah you
had a line in that and then are you no I
didn't do that no I'm saying
but then were you also because we were
laughing with uh crush on her so hard I
think my brother told me it's your voice
yeah we're laughing at you know when uh
he hits the button at the holidays
ninja it's him yeah I was like me and
were laughing because I go imagine Louie
doing that man be so funny like y'all
record that they were in an art museum
or something what was this yeah it was
funny was Louie just was good to me and
he put me on that show every season in
some capacity
and the third season was something I
didn't want to it was something the joke
was like shirt off fat guy underwear and
I was like it's not my
and uh
when I don't think I was I think it was
like away also so I was able to use that
as an excuse more in like the
uh they want to be a fat naked guy but
they want to get me something so he was
like hey would you want to do this and I
was like sure how do I do it he's like
just go on your phone voice memos and
record it saying in a bunch of different
ways and so I don't it's gone I don't
know why it's gone but on my phone
somewhere there was a good thing it was
like too much by the way it's like the
you know the all different ways you know
I mean so you're like ninja ninja
it was such a funny bit did you did you
also do the scream in the meow and the
moo uh no no no no no no none of that
okay
that was so shockingly funny it was just
like oh my God Louis CK
but it's hilarious you know everyone's
worried about getting that Joe Rogan
Mega mix they make I'm like it's in my
phone myself I just recorded my own yeah
I'll put in my own Mega mix of n words
because I promise you it was for a
production yeah
what else you got Jen uh you want some
more we good uh we've been going a hot
second we've been going hot second yeah
and then uh damn it's 350 oh [__] all
right but uh Big J's new special
dropping soon my new dog belly spec new
dog dog belly dog bellies
yeah so my dog it's a weird one word
down yeah since it's released new dog
belly comedy special on YouTube that's
awesome dude yeah I'm excited about
April 5th well you've always been one of
my favorites I think oh man you're one
of the great Comics I've never seen you
not be hilarious so um I'm looking
forward to it I appreciate that when I
uh so when I first went with uh truce
initially like that was like the so you
and already Lang were both like client
says and I was like hell yeah yeah yeah
and then it turns out he doesn't know
anything outside of like he was good for
like sketch stuff like acting stuff is
what it was I just needed stand up stuff
yeah I was only interested in acting
Rogan Rogan would always be back then
Rogan was like just stand up just stand
up I was like no no I want to be an
actor do stand up stand up I'd be an
acting class we got in fights like
[__] at dinner do [__] this acting
class get the [__] out of here start
doing stand-up what's your passion more
for now stand up 100 of course yeah
don't like acting never did like acting
never been on a set where I didn't want
it to be over how about that is that
true yeah and that's the truth come to
that truth it's completely
I get [__] a lot of time for that
especially with the agencies and stuff
like that where they're like I go dude
uh
I was on set on Hustlers on the strip
club DJ I'm in the movie I'm in the
movie for a cumulative minute you hear
my voice a couple times I even have a
thing
where I uh what you call JLo gives me
money yeah
I I watched her do that day I introduced
the dance she does in that movie where
she looks amazing and yeah it's boring
you on set for house party beat three
days yeah 14 hours a day yeah and I'm I
reflect on it even as all those when I
got to watch like yeah they're like you
got to watch Jayla do that dance he goes
45 minutes 45 minutes and then it was
like hot outside and too cold in so like
I could go to a trailer that's not like
people go like oh the trailers are great
it's a Will Smith's Trail or no [__]
yeah
I started I really just don't like it
Soder loves it so it does like not me
I'm starting them I hated it I never
liked any of it you you're waiting all
the time I want the day to be over me
and Johnny
on uh Ride Along for I don't know how
long maybe I'm whatever and it was a
legit part and when John was there and
we were sitting there in the trailer
this is Johnny legs we're in the trailer
like [__] reading plays playing doing
whatever we can it's just sitting around
waiting time you just wait I think it'd
be different if like you did a like a
comedy buddy movie like all your boys
from Legion Escape
but then yeah
to me it's more like I like the like
what what Bert's doing
to me was a god of the dream I went on
those tours with the metal bands years
ago like opening for that was always on
production buses because I was just a
solo comic on a Music Tour yeah and but
being on that and becoming friends with
like the uh the band that was opening on
that tour two cents they're the band
that plays uh all my specials they
always play the music for it and um I
saw those guys go that was their first
Tour on a tour bus together oh and I was
envious of that I was like I want to do
that like my exact pick of friends like
the way Bird's doing on a tour bus yeah
but Bart's got such it's such a big
production there's so much going on it's
a lot of things I almost mean more just
like you and the boys me and the boys
and a tour manager and whatever and a
PlayStation and movie you know I mean
going around yeah the big Productions
got a lot going on yeah it's like almost
like a pressure to be like hey we have
to have a big hangout at the end of
every night filming everything yeah and
by the way he's right and I'm wrong on
like the amount you've got to be putting
out content or it's right about it but
these birds different but catching me on
that was the funniest it was like
remember standing in front of the bus
one morning just like I mean like in a
tank you know wife beater and basketball
shorts I just woke up
hair's all [__] up and he was like Hey
you having fun so far I go yeah dude
this is absolutely incredible holy [__]
looks like a focus there's like a guy
holding the thing yeah like were you
guys all behind me this whole time we've
been with you since you woke up I've
been probably making noises outside
camera shoot
and it was Avatar two angles are my
surprise yeah I look down I'm wearing
all of those nodes what
Thursday's just Friday Saturday
it says Thursday Friday Saturday
oh is it just Friday Saturday yeah do my
goobies if you're in Maryland everybody
I keep telling them this Baltimore it's
[__] man it's a great room it's a
cool uh it's a big tall like the
ceilings are tall it's fun that's where
that fight happened yeah I know I've
done it before
March 31 April 1. all right let's go
then I got helium uh April 20 22 and uh
oh look Comedy Zone in Port Charlotte
visani theater May 4 5 and 6. let's go
all right kids love you ice house this
Saturday you know you won't be here
though invite you uh ice house this
Saturday shopping friends want you only
8 P.M new ice house then Atlanta is
April 13th through the 15th The Comedy
Store La Jolla just went on sale that's
June 2nd through the 4th and then I'm
over across the pond Belfast Glasgow
Manchester London Cardiff double Roscoe
Glasgow tickets at thickpoint.com love
you guys big Jay go watch your special
drops April 5th dog belly you're one of
the best doing it man okay please come
stop by brother thank you for having the
best